they narrowly escaped russian occupation
and after three months the kogilitsky
family have returned home
but they've lost everything
and they're now living in a train
carriage as they try to piece their
lives back together
this is six
this is your
new home
absolutely
[Music]
they're back in the kiev suburb of a pin
that's as close as the russians got to
the capital in this war
as bombs dropped on their neighborhood
they witnessed unthinkable horrors
um
even in the shelter of their train a
reminder the threat remains here the
carriage windows taped up to protect
from the impact of further bombings
the family made the decision to return
because twelve-year-old vlad missed his
friends
but his school has been destroyed
[Music]
his summer holidays are quite a contrast
to most children
they invited us to see what was left of
their neighborhood
bullet holes and destroyed buildings
lined the roads
a chilling reminder it was only in the
spring this leafy suburb was terrorized
by street to street fighting
my goodness
we first stop at the family's garage to
say there was nothing left is an
understatement
there wasn't a lot for this family to
come home to
but an important family member was left
behind
elisa
eventually they find her
you sense the family's daily visits are
as much for them
almost everyone you meet here is scarred
by this war
everyone coping in their own way
sally lockwood sky news open